rolling how powerful is a kiss can it
heal something that's broken or break
something that's healed 4x couples
agreed to kiss on camera this is their
story
franca this girl I met after a show we
did it for like 7 months it's gone well
and then I went back home to Germany
which came back it's kind of like I just
lost touch a little bit I don't even
know what I want out of this I still
kind of like her
Maggie's my high-school sweetheart our
families have been friends for a really
long time and we are friends all
throughout high school we just started
dating and of my senior year and then
she went off to college which stops a
relationship we started this this affair
and around boundless times day it was
over a month later because I was still
involved with someone else we both know
where we stand with each other I have a
hard time getting out of relationships
alex is a very unique person I would say
Dom is a little uptight the big thing
was is that she's kind of like
chronically basically late to everything
he's also the type of person that was
like very into coasters we've had sex on
this table why can't a cup be on this
table
[Music]
hola hey what's up
nada cool though
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
they work kiss was amazing it was great
I didn't feel that like a shield yeah
just not yeah we haven't talked in a
while but like you know if you want and
that's the time the kiss doesn't change
a normal ya know like for this moment
super strange like once I leave it's
totally not know that was just wildly
personal yeah yeah well it's gonna kiss
pits you know the voice in your head
that's like oh I should get back with my
ex I really miss her that voice is a lie
I think he's a good ol place where we
can kiss again you know deli food in a
bench make out with a beverage extra key
what do you want you know you're not
you're not set on the turkey no no
you're flexible jinx I think everyone
should stay friends we're really good
friends and we have an awesome
relationship now so you can say friends
yeah I'll call you sometime
no you are
[Music]
[Music]